Today I think I'll compare Portuguese
with a special dialect of Portuguese
called Spanish.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is how similar or Spanish
and Portuguese,
as you probably know,
Spanish and Portuguese are both Ibero
Romance languages that share a common
origin.
There are different enough that they are
definitely considered different
languages,
but they're also closely related and
quite similar in many ways.
On paper,
the two languages look very similar and
speakers of either language can
generally read the other language
without too much trouble.
The spoken language is however,
are more different from each other and
less mutually intelligible than the
written forms and Portuguese speakers
typically understand spoken Spanish
better than Spanish speakers understand
Portuguese because Portuguese speakers
as smart.
Well actually it's mostly because of the
difference in pronunciation between the
two languages,
but we'll get into that a little later.
Spanish and Portuguese share about 89
percent lexical similarity,
meaning that 89 percent of the words
have a cognate or an equivalent in the
other language.
Now,
that doesn't always mean that 89 percent
of the words will be the same because
some of the different words are very
basic and common words,
and even though cognate words often look
and sound quite similar,
there are other cognates that have
developed quite differently and now
sound and look quite different.
For instance,
this pair of cognates clearly resemble
each other in Spanish and in Portuguese.